so they're making a Beauty and the Beast
horror movie and there's a trailer for
it so my first thought when I found out
about this is that they're trying to
cash in on this whole Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey phenomena and basically
what happened is the original Winnie the
Pooh tale is now old enough to where
it's in the public domain and anyone can
use that character so they decided to
make a horror movie but I think there is
a problem if they kind of overdo this
and do too much I know the creators of
Winnie the Pooh already have more plans
if we look at this article it talks
about Winnie the Pooh blood and honey
but they're also planning on making
horror movies based on other public
domain characters including Bambi the
Reckoning and Peter Pan and Neverland
Nightmare and I just think part of the
reason that people were drawn to Winnie
the Pooh is the fact that you don't
expect horror to be associated with it
so whether people found it creepy or
they just saw it because they found it
funny the main reason that people saw it
is because it is unexpected as for the
Beauty and the Beast horror movie I'm
willing to give it a little bit more of
a pass because the original Disney movie
is already based on a fairy tale and it
wasn't necessarily ever supposed to be a
kids thing the story itself may actually
lend itself better to horror just based
on the trailer it doesn't look like it's
going to be amazing follow for more
horror news right